this fourth of July weekend the country
we broke away from is struggling with
its own independence issues specifically
how to leave the European Union three
years after the brexit vote Britain is
no closer to agreeing to a deal and how
to leave the EU a group of four
campaigners in London has taken it upon
themselves to launch a passionate plea
to remain in Europe shining a very
public spotlight on the politicians who
promised brexit would be easy Debora
patta has more it may not look like the
setting for a hotbed of revolutionary
activity but this innocuous London pub
was exactly where an audacious guerrilla
campaign was born when four young dads
decided to hold politicians to account
for the bricks at chaos nobody was going
back to those politicians as saying hang
on in June 2016 you promised this you
said that you said we hold all the cards
you said we've got the European Union
over a barrel bricks it has already sunk
- Prime Minister's throne favourable
European trade deals into uncertainty
and lifts a nation bitterly divided and
yet three years after the UK voted to
leave the EU it is still no closer to an
agreed exit plan despite the looming
October departure date as James Olly
been and will drowned their bricks at
sorrows a simple plan was hatched why
not throw politicians own words back at
them the day after we vote to leave we
hold all the cards
the idea was to emblazon the quotes on
huge public billboards the only problem
was they had no idea or how to do it the
first night we came out and did it was a
bit of a disaster we didn't really have
the right tools we didn't have the paste
and the right thickness billboards
rounded off with their now infamous
tagline hashtag led by donkeys turns out
there's a lot to be said for laughing at
those in power we feel that by laughing
in them we remove a little bit of their
power as well so we've quite enjoyed
calling them donkeys but nobody was
laughing when their amateur billboards
turned into a nationwide phenomenon
as 1 million people marched in London
earlier this year demanding a second
referendum on brakes it led by donkeys
found themselves hiring helicopters with
the help of crowdfunding to capture a
banner that would be held aloft by the
marchers well could we get a drone oh no
you can't fly drones during this protest
and well no could we get helicopter so
we googled it in the first answer for
helicopters to hire another 5,000 pounds
and we had a helicopter in the air so
yeah I mean it was singularly the most
stressful thing we've done and because
they're pulling out a huge banner like
that over a crowd comes with a lot of
responsibility but actually for me it
gave us one of the greatest returns the
banner became a defining moment of the
day now funded by online donations and
no longer stealing ad space the group
have revealed their identities and have
upped their game with projections in
Brussels as well as poking fun at
international visitors and empowering
isn't it because I think one of the
things is that people are feeling
powerless suddenly these quotes these
promises that were made before the
referendum became a fundamental part of
the debate and I would like to think
that's because we sat here frustrated
printed out a poster and slapped it up
on a billboard side with some cheap
wallpaper paste as for the future I
think all of us generally are optimists
and I don't feel in my heart of hearts
that we are going to leave the opinion
at the end of October while staying in
the EU might be unlikely
it wouldn't be the craziest thing to
happen in British politics over the past
three years for CBS this morning
Saturday Debora patta London